alors emmanuel macron est clairement
président du coa question c'est parti le
débat sur le président où on va revenir
sur tous les sujets ce soir jimmy
mohamed vous dit non non parce que
malgré les bonnes choses qu'il a pu
faire elle reste entaché d'un bilan
assez catastrophique on a vu la retraite
les la cg qui était augmentée les appels
pour les étudiants on a eu la taxe qui a
donné les gilet jaune sur l'essence et
puis ça nous fait pas oublier toutes les
bonnes choses qui ont pu être faites
comme par exemple le fait qu'on ait
dédoubler les classes de cp dans des
zones prix d'éducation prioritaire ça on
oublie que des cotisations sociales ont
été supprimés pour des étudiants à
l'entrée la faculté on regarde que ce
bilan négatif est on est on est un peu
obsédé le on a reculé beaucoup sur le
plastique et puis dire une chose
incroyable le la moralisation de la vie
politique
finalement ce rendez compte qu'on a
jamais eu autant de ministres et
premiers ministres qui ont démissionné
si on fait la liste ils sont tous été
empêtré dans les affaires et puis le
dernier pas ne peut pas le pré ministre
monsieur delevoye qui donne qui fait la
réforme des retraites qui finalement a
été payé pour travailler dans des
intérêts privés
bref malgré tout toutes les bonnes
choses qui pourra faire ça restera à mon
sens un échec ce quinqua les jeux
prendre bernard bernard laporte avec moi
je dis oui à puce d'autant plus
facilement que j'ai pas voté pour lui
donc oui j'ai voté pour lui d'un taux
mais au départ d'andy pour métaux gérez
votre pour ses parodies paul oui j'ai eu
la chance de le rencontrer l'équipe de
france de rugby et 4,5 fois sur des
shows des finales et ses 18 allée lui
j'étais convaincu que l'on mettait un
beau mec comme on dit dans le jargon du
sport et je suis j'étais rassuré là
dessus c'est qu'un cadre à proximité ça
c'est clair
après jimmy viens de dire est ce qu'il
est - ce qui leur donne à manger aux
loyalistes monde qu'il a été élu par les
français
les mosquées j'ai envie que la france et
réussissent jallet maroc on crache pas
ce que je dis qu'il est président on lui
crache dessus
il y avait ça qu'on dit après il ya eu
la médaille à maquereau nommé y en aura
une autre il va toujours caché sur le
pedn cracher ce président ou de manama
les traditions décidé que c'était lui et
moi j'ai dit il faut qu'ils réussissent
et tout comme je disais c'est théo
l'année j'ai pas voté pour lui il faut
qu'on la met réussisse
j'ai envie que la france gagne et moi
moment-là d'oreilles que pour ça que
j'avais à dire oui c'est mon président à
tous les papas faits jim il a dit il va
pas te reprendre point par point
bien des choses qui sont très bien faits
d'autres qui sont moins bien fait c'est
clair mais moi ce que j'ai envie c'est
qu'on soit fiers de notre pays et que
soient fiers de notre président quel
qu'il soit
voilà c'est comme ça pour laurent
seillier vous dit non ce n'était pas
évident parce que je me suis posé la
question longuement non
alors parce qu'elle était porte parole
des républicains néanmoins comme bernard
moi j'ai envie que la world et compte
uplay oui j'ai envie que la france
réussisse donc j'avais pas envie de dire
que le président n'était pas un bon
président et il a été élu et beaucoup
mettre en cause son élection que ce
qu'on trouve déjà ça totalement anti
républicain donc j'ai longuement hésité
j'ai failli faire un entre deux mais
c'est pas mon style mais alors j'ai fait
une photographie du pays
et puis je me suis dit est ce que les
français vont bien mais non les français
souffrent il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
souffrance il ya beaucoup d'insécurité
il ya beaucoup de doutes il ya une
véritable crise en france donc je me
suis pas sentie si vous voulez à dire
que c'était un bon président parce
qu'effectivement même si tout n'est pas
lié à son action évidemment il ya une
action internationale sur laquelle et
d'un contexte économique sur lequel il
ne peut pas beaucoup agir mais néanmoins
je pense que ça aurait été un peu en
décalage de dire que c'est un bon
président alors que le pays ne va pas
bien du tout par contre j'espère que
l'expérience de ce début de quinquennat
lui servira et qu'il va corriger ses
erreurs et qu'après on pourra tout se
dire que c'est un bon président et
qu'ils finissent le quinquennat avec des
très bonnes choses positives alors
licorne et reste avec nous licorne pour
moi personnellement j'ai jamais voulu en
tant que président et pour moi il n'est
pas parce que j'attendais en fait
préféré mâcon épaves outil de production
si vraiment la consule semaine avec un
des deux frères qui bonne question avec
eric naulleau avec non mais il n'est pas
prévu dans les vacances il doit alors
donc sa beauté président ramon personnes
et puis je partirai en vacances avec
aucun des deux donc c'est un mauvais
président pour vous oui parce que moi
j'ai été beaucoup déçu parce que c'est
beaucoup retranché lors justement des
mouvements des ligier les jaunes les a
jamais affrontés face à face moi j'aime
bien le face à face justement pour
pouvoir parler discuter échanger et ben
il est resté en retrait et ne les a
jamais nommé genre dire gilet jaune
c'est comme si c'était quelque chose de
ça lui donne une maladie kouao quelque
chose et vous aviez pas voté pour lui ni
aux pros mais les noms rapport au
premier tour n'est pas voté pour lui non
du tout je ne connaissais pas
sincèrement vous connaissez pas non
d'accord invité au ministre la femme ou
alors aller au nouristan raquel garrido
bien sûr je vous demander votre avis
là-dessus
sans surprise non si ç'avait été mais
l'ancienne place vous auriez fait quoi
au gouvernement ou à j'aurais bien aimé
être à l'assemblée constituante
parce que l'idée c'était tout de suite
forger une sixième république notre
conscience que j'allais finir par
apprendre ce que c'est l'assemblée
constitue le mistral aux règles de la
vème république elles ne sont pas
nouvelles
ah oui chérie qui vous mange sixième
république mais par exemple moi je
voulais m'occuper de ça
balayés ministre de la vème république
moi je pense que c'est pas très
intéressant et que c'est un système
d'une sorte de monarchie plus ils sont
plus ne s'est pas intéressé pour sa déjà
long sur un truc sur mâcon est ce que
c'est un bon ou un mauvais président moi
je pense que c'est un mauvais président
ou parce que il a été élu avec un score
important face à marine le pen et il a
fait semblant que le vote qui avait
recueilli par rejet de marine le pen
était en fait un vote d'adhésion pour
lui ça je trouve que c'est une astuce
pas très honnête et ça explique tout le
reste on fait ça explique qu'ils
gouvernent pour certains petit groupe à
chaque fois plus étroit de personnes
fortunées privilégiée est qu'il ait pas
finalement le président de tous les
français
voilà je pense que c'est ça qui est ce
qu'on peut lui reprocher vous l'équipe
art alors oui et en plus je pense qui
prend les gens un peu de haut y compris
en maniant des fois on va dire le
mensonge je prends juste un exemple qui
a eu lieu hier
hier le gouvernement a dit que la
réforme des retraites ne s'appliquerait
pas aux personnes qui sont nées avant
1975 et il a suffi qu'on regarde les
communiqués de presse dossier de presse
avec la police écrit comme dans les
contrats de banques ont poli suite pour
s'apercevoir qu'on fait si puisque l'aja
64 ans à s'appliquer en fait dès le 1er
janvier 2022 à tout le monde
bon donc ça c'est pas correct parce que
les gens n'aiment pas être pris pour des
cons il faut dire la vérité aux gens à
quel rose ameziane vous trouvez que
c'est un bon président oui je trouve que
c'est un mime président ne serait ce que
pour sa capacité
à vouloir réformer un pays beaucoup ont
essayé de le faire la droite a essayé de
faire et beaucoup d'ailleurs chez les
républicains
on rêvait pas mal de réformes notamment
celles de la sncf
donc pour son courage pour son envie
pour son énergie je salue son travail
après il est vrai que tout n'est pas
parfait dans ce quinquennat il ya
parfois des problèmes de communication
des problèmes de méthode des problèmes
de pédagogie on l'a vu dernièrement avec
avec cette grève on a vu aussi également
avec la crise sociale des gilets jaunes
on l'a vu aussi mon page par exemple je
partage pas ce qui s'est passé avec le
plan banlieues où l'on retrouve pas dans
les détails voilà je sais c'est assez
rapide
est ce que c'est un bon président moi
c'est un bon président ne serait ce que
pour au niveau de la scène
internationale il a été capable d'être
contre trump date d'affirmer ses
positions
donc moi je trouve qu'il a une bonne
image à l'international et en france
il a envie de réformer il essaye c'est
dur c'est pas évident mais rien que pour
ça je le salue eric naulleau non moi je
dis oui et non oui parce qu'il met en
application ce qu'ils avaient annoncé on
en avait perdu l'habitude mitterrand au
bout de deux ans c'était la rigueur
chirac au bout de six mois ce n'est plus
la fracture sociale mais c'était
l'austérité et hollande nous avait dit
que la finance était son ennemi vu comme
il a traité la finance
on se demande comment il traite ses amis
très agréable d'être un ami de françois
hollande
ai je dit non parce qu'ils portent une
responsabilité personnelle écrasante
dans la crise il a multiplié les petites
phrases maladroites vis-à-vis de
français de tous les jours de base est
il à braquer tout le monde par une forme
d'arrogance tout simplement parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui a vécu un peu en
apesanteur qui a jamais été au contact
de la france réelle et je trouve que son
apprentissage est un peu long et même en
tant que technocrates
je ne trouve pas si douée que ça je
trouve que la manière dont a été abordé
la réforme des retraites sur le plan de
la méthode a été catastrophique donc si
je dois penchée entre le oui et le non
ce sera plutôt non mais je lui sais gré
de ne pas faire comme les autres
c'est-à-dire d'oublier son programme dès
qu'il est au pouvoir il n'aurait
zhentarim écoute moi j'ai mis un entre
deux parce que ça fait longtemps dans
notre pays que quand on est citoyen on
vote plus pour le meilleur on vote pour
le moins mauvais donc je pense que ça a
été effectivement la démarche qui a été
engagé par ceux qui ont voté manuel
macro ont voté pour le moins mauvais
sans rêver parce que je crois qu'on
croit plus au père noël il a
accueilli une situation quand même de
notre pays qui était difficile en deux
ans et demi il n'y a pas de baguette
magique et on peut pas changer le visage
de la france en deux ans et demi avec
des gens qui souffrent les a reçus sur
notre plateau nous régulièrement et sans
mandat les services publics les
infirmières les fonctionnaires de police
et des enseignants
donc ça c'est quand même pas emmanuel
macron qui en a la responsabilité
si bien intérieurs alors après est-ce
que emmanuel macron a tout mis en oeuvre
pour redresser la barre moi ya une chose
qui me dérange emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron quelqu'un qui est brillantissime
c'est le premier de la classe en
revanche ils pensent qu' on doit faire
comme si on était tous des premiers de
la classe dans le pays et des gens qui
souffrent les gens qui sont sur le bord
du chemin
je trouve qu'il leur porte pas assez
d'attention pas assez de considération
passé de bienveillance il donne le
sentiment que tout le monde peut aller
au même rythme avec la même capacité à
trouver sa place dans la société
ce serait trop beau ça n'est pas le cas
or il donne le sentiment de faire une
politique pour les gens qui lui
ressemble qui vont vite
nokia qui sont plutôt bien doté donc
dans la société et qui ont des capacités
à réussir
il ne fait pas assez pour les français
qui souffrent et j'ai été frappé par une
chose qui m'a mis mal à l'aise au début
de son mandat
c'est qu'il s'est attaqué avec la hausse
de la csg des retraités pauvres et sa
une société qui respecte pas ses aînés
la paire une société qui n'a pas
d'avenir
alors christine juste un exemple il ya
vingt secondes
ça fait dix ans que je me bagarre pour
les familles monoparentales et premières
victimes de la pauvreté en france
j'ai milité pour rencontrer l'elysée
pour alerter sur ce sujet qui étaient
les premières sur les ronds points pour
les gilet jaune et pour dire je dis que
oui sermon président bien sûr il n'est
pas parfait mais il a réussi à changer
les textes les pensions alimentaires
pour les familles monoparentales pour ça
j'ose dire merci président pour ses
premières victimes de la pauvreté
alors on va voir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs vous n'avez pas tous
prêts à dire sur tous les sujets non
voilà oui à 24% non à 76 % pour les
téléspectateurs